[Musique]
puis à montréal samedi dernier il ya eu
une marche sa manifestation qui était
oui à montréal mais aussi à travers le
monde là où il ya la dia des diaspora
tchadienne
une marche qui portait le nom ou le
titre dix ans la justice l'inclusion et
l'alternance en 2021
justement on fait ça en référence à ces
assisses élection présidentielle en
avril prochain dans votre pays d'origine
donc votre parti un candidat
capitalisait potentiel pour la
présidentielle
c'est le docteur en économie succès
massera et vous me disiez tout à l'heure
à voir dans près à l'entrevue que
monsieur massera se trouve actuellement
dans l'ambassade américaine au tchad
qu'est ce qui se passe pourquoi il est
là oui mais justement notre président
c'est tout lui et se trouve à
l'ambassade pour leur sécurité
et lorsque nous avons organisé la marche
aussi si vous vous souvenez et je disais
que au pays au tchad marché et qu'il
vous a signé son arrêt de mort et parce
que ils ont marché le pouvoir vous avoir
leur peau ont été l'expression est donc
voilà il a fallu que notre président nos
camarades se réfugier pour leur sécurité
à l'ambassade des états unis
cad et ce n'est pas les seuls parce
qu'on a aussi procédé à l'arrestation
d'une centaine de personnes notamment la
trésorière notre fatigue mais un autre
militant aujourd'hui se tournant plus
donc c'est pour vous dire que le marché
qui n est presque au tchad marché ou
manifester au tchad équivaut à signer
son arrêt de mort ce matin dans les
journaux
quinze partis d'opposition dans votre
pays ont des signes et
candidat unique messier théophile
benbouzid bongo roues ce néophyte en
politique et donc il sera le candidat
unique à l'élection présidentielle du 11
avril en même temps votre parti qui est
aussi un parti d'opposition présents de
notre candidat dites nous quelle
ambiance avec vous présentez un peu
l'ambiance déjà en ce qui concerne ces
marches qui ont eu lieu samedi et puis
les les
les contrecoups 10 ans d'aidé et
manifester mais de manière générale que
les l'ambiance préélectorale au tchad en
ce moment c'est tout ce qui a deux
comprenez que les partis d'opposition
ceux qui font des nouvelles c'est qu'ils
envoient des messages
ils n'ont pas l'eau doit aujourd'hui
effet papa ou dillon le président de la
république et son parti au pouvoir
ils vont y voyagent à travers le tchad
pour faire campagne aux amis politiques
l'opposition à l'eau doit de répondre ou
dis bien deux poids deux mesures dans
une démocratie qui se respecte pour
faire ça et dire que le président
lui-même il est petit et enfin de temps
la compétition contre lui même l'un des
seuls en selle et il fait la compétition
avec l'une les autres partis font ce
qu'ils peuvent pour les oppositions je
veux dire on sait qu'ils peuvent
s'organiser
grâce à une machine qui de toute façon
le résultat de cette élection est connu
d'avancé on creuse ajouté que l'entente
s'est délecté complètement
antidémocratique jamais dans les agendas
sorte de comédie et quelques jets de
pierre
il faut expliquer aussi monsieur mila
éthiques
le président actuel président sortant
donc idriss deby itno est au pouvoir
depuis 30 ans et puis il a été
21 ans si je comprends bien au moins
trente ans donc il a été investi encore
une fois pour un sixième mandat
briguer un sixième mandat par son parti
en fin de semaine dans les derniers
jours
donc quel avec quels arguments 10 ans
peut-on vouloir rester trente ans après
30 ans d'être pouvoir justement madame
[Musique]
toute raison je ne vois pas quelles
raisons qui restent à ces niveaux avec
des résultats le plus vous savez les
propos de ce sont des chats pelés de la
catastrophe que le tabac est connu il
reviendra là dessus mais l'un des
slogans de notre marche ici c'est fini
et c'était non au sixième mandat de ce
type à ce que toi décennies si vous
n'avez rien en dépit des énormes
richesses du tchad et ensoleillé c'est
presque même l'utilisation du soleil
peut nous apporter de l'électricité ou
ta dernière où je vous renvoie à lire
simplement les intérêts particuliers le
thème harry pour jour au bas de
l'échelle en dépit de ça en dépit de
tout bon sens
des tenues président veut se représenter
il a ou aura bien qu'il a 70 ans disons
de je ne sais pas ce qu'on apporte après
ça donc je ne vois aucun
et puis ce souvenir est en paix ses
désirs se présentait donc si je
comprends bien d'enfants cette marche
qui a eu lieu comme comme on dit c'est
un peu partout dans le monde
organisés par les différentes diasporas
tchadienne à travers le monde avec
l'objectif donc de parler de ce qui se
passe au tchad parce que c'est un pays
dont on ne parle pas souvent le canada
maintient des relations commerciales
avec la plupart des pays dans le
comme vous dites le tchad a des
ressources naturelles très importante
surtout au niveau du pétrole donc mais
si vous saviez un message du son à
passer du gouvernement canadien à ce qui
concerne ce qui se passe dans votre pays
a attiré peut-être l'attention qu'elle
serait t'il ce message
or je demande aux attaques y adhèrent
avec l'auteur ils sont aussi dans la
mire francophonie est donc le canari le
canada a délivré justement pour
s'intéresser et pour réparer près le
sort restait sort de cette 10ème et des
caddies en ce moment sur l'actuel régime
sous d'origine du sénat d je m'excuse
des débits
le canada est un pays de liberté là où
le droit de l'eau partout il ya la
répression le canada a toujours répondu
présent sa marque armani c'était la même
chose ce qui est bon pour ces pays là
c'est bon aussi pour les tchadiens
c'est pas un pays où en était la preuve
de soutien et que j'ai subi six
canadiennes donc nous partageons la même
humanité et nous demandons à ce que le
canadien de près ce qui se passe
eric dane le sort qui croupissent sur
une dictature depuis trois décennies
alors le gouvernement que les partis
d'opposition que les gens s'intéressent
à ces 17 drame qui se joue finalement à
huit clos au tchad alors nous voulons
prayssas l'attention des autorités d'ici
et aux canadiennes ensemble que des
drames qui se jouent tranquillement dans
cette partie du monde qui s'appelle le
cadre les échanges bilatéraux de
marchandises entre le canada et le tchad
s'élève à 9 millions de dollars en 2018
en fait ça a été le cas mais j'imagine
que ça s'est maintenue et puis que les
principales exportations canadiennes
des marchandises vers le chat totalisent
8 millions presque 9 millions de dollars
ou 6 par année donc il ya il y a des
lignes et commerciaux parlez moi
justement de quelle quel type de de lien
existe entre la classe politique
canadienne et la classe politique qui à
10,1 aujourd'hui hélas nous travaillons
en ce moment à travers notre parti juste
mal être c'est qu'on a et que les partis
politiques soient de l'opposition ou
calle et qu'il nous écoute qu'il écoute
les représentants propositions nous
sommes nous relayons la boîte c'est
parti d'un coup et qui existe dans nos
différents pays et donc en l'occurrence
il s'agit du tad de sorte à ce que nous
leur transmettons les informations de
plus réel plus factuel et nous savons
qu'ils sont ils sont très très attentif
à nos questions de droits de l'homme
une chose est donc nous n'avons pas de
liens plus forts au niveau politique
ça serait l'idéal donc oui oui tout à
fait et je le disais oublions le tchad
fait partie de l'afrique où l'hymne à cô
folie et le canada aussi le québec vous
voyez où y sont dans la même instance et
donc le canada à des leviers ou laisser
de s'intéresser de près au sort des
populations
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont les prochaines
étapes pour votre parti pour le
président de votre parti qui est comme
on dit c'est c'est trop aujourd'hui même
l'ambassade américaine au tchad donc
quelles sont les prochaines étapes pour
le moment les priorités donc pour les
prochaines semaines mois il est la
priorité et c'est de kino tous nos
camarades qui est tous les terriens qui
sont ré et qui se trouve en prison soit
libéré pour permettre également à notre
vision de sortir de là parce que aussi
longtemps que les gens sont prison puis
c'est pas son sort qui l'intéressent et
que c'était l'une des conditions qu'il a
dit ça c'est la priorité est aussi
vous les 10 en primeur que nous allons
aviser ses 5 10 ou 13 à montréal
et cette fois ci et ça sert l ensemble
des tchadiens
l'ensemble des canadiennes l'ensemble
des associations de les partis
politiques qu'ils viennent nous soutenir
et nous demandons la libération si d'ici
là cette libération ne se conduisent pas
mais aussi de leur expliquer davantage
ce qui se passe quand ils comprennent
nous avons québécoise qui ne nous laisse
pas dans cette super des dictatures qui
enfin de nous écraser chaque les
tchadiens à spirou si avec maladie
n'importe quel peuple
il n'y a pas de raison ni moralisme
quelque sorte ce soit pour les maintenir
sous cette nature dont commis dans les
jours qui viennent
nous sommes déjà à l'action réalisée et
ça c'est dans l'ensemble du monde est
tout l'été ce corps y compris aux tables
nous allons encore marcher à 12h13 donc
voilà c'est un appel que je lance à
toutes les associations une dalle au nom
de tous à montréal l'autre sens mais qui
pèse pour marcher on en est resté le
glam et justement les foyers farnham
ils sont derrière la justice l'inclusion
et l'alternance l'alternance et la
respiration de la démocratie que l'on y
a pas d'alternance
adam qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire un et
pour un peu évolué les enfants qui sont
nés où joue autant et ils n'ont connu
qu'un seul président il veut encore
rempilé pour 7 ans et vous écoutez ccsat
défie toute logique tout le bon sens
mais voilà c'est ça la réalité du talent
dans lequel nous vivons nos compatriotes
assis benjamin mullaittivu sept
représentants au canada du parti les
transformateurs sont partis au tchad et
c'est un des partis qui présentent un
candidat pour la prochaine élection
présidentielle
en avril prochain merci beaucoup c'est
moi qui vous remercie madame
[Musique]